how would you describe this current
moment in AI machine learning whatever
we want to call it
I think it's a pivotal moment chat GPT
has shown that these big language models
can do amazing things and the general
public has suddenly caught on yeah we
have because Microsoft released
something
and they're suddenly aware of stuff that
people of the big companies have been
aware of for the last five years yeah
what did you think the first time you
used chat GPT
um
it's well I've used lots of things that
came before chat gpg that were quite
similar so chat GPD itself
didn't amaze me much gpt2 which was one
of the earlier language Brands amazed me
and a model at Google amazed me that
could actually explain why a joke was
funny oh really yeah in just natural
language it'll tell you yeah you tell it
a joke not for all jokes but for quite a
few of them it can tell you why it's
funny okay and that you it seems very
hard to say it doesn't understand when
it can tell you why a joke's funny so if
chat GPT wasn't
all that surprising or impressive were
you surprised by The public's reaction
to it because the reaction was big
yes I think everybody was a bit
surprised by how big the reaction was
that it was the sort of fastest growing
up ever yeah
um
maybe we shouldn't have been surprised
but people the researchers had kind of
got used to the fact that these things
actually worked yeah you were famously
like
half a century ahead of the curve on
this AI stuff go ahead correct me go
ahead not really not really because
there were two schools of thought in AI
um there was mainstream Ai and then
there was years but it was all about
friends yeah that thought it was all
about reasoning and logic and then there
was neural Nets which won't call AI then
um
which thought that you better study
biology because those were the only
things that really worked
and so mainstream AI based its theories
on reasoning and logic and we based our
theories on the idea that connections
between neurons change and that's how
you learn
and it turned out in the long run
um
we came up trumps
um but in the short term it looked kind
of hopeless well looking back knowing
what you know now do you think there's
anything you could have said then that
would have convinced people
I could have said it then but it
wouldn't have convinced people and what
I could have said then is the only
reason that neural networks weren't
working really well in the 1980s was
because the computers weren't fast
enough and the data sets weren't big
enough
but back in the 80s
the big issue was could you expect a big
neural network with lots of neurons in
it compute nodes and connections between
them that learns by just changing the
strengths of the connections could you
expect that to just look at data and
with no kind of innate prior knowledge
learn how to do things and people in
mainstream AI thought that was
completely ridiculous it sounds a little
ridiculous it is a little ridiculous but
it works
and how did you know or why did you
Intuit that it would work because the
brain works because that's you have to
explain how come we can do things and
how come we can do things like we didn't
evolve for like reading reading's much
too recent for us to have had
significant evolutionary input to it but
we can learn to do that and Mathematics
we can learn that so there must be a way
to learn in these neural networks
yesterday Nick Frost who used to work
with you told us that you are not really
that interested in creating AI your core
interest is just in understanding how
the brain works yes I'd really like to
understand how the brain works obviously
if your failed theories of how the brain
works lead to good technology you cash
in on that and it gets get grants and
things but
um I really would like to know how the
brain works and I think there's
currently a Divergence between the
artificial neural networks that are the
basis of all this new Ai and how the
brain actually works I think they're
going different routes now so we're
still not
going about it the right way
that's what I believe this is my
personal opinion but all of the big
models now use a technique called back
propagation which you helped popularize
popularize in the 80s very good
um and I don't think that's what the
brain is doing explain why okay there's
a fundamental difference between two
different there's two different paths to
intelligence
so One path is a biological path where
you have Hardware that's a bit flaky an
analog so what we have to do is
communicate by using natural language
also by showing people how to do these
imitation and things like that but
instead of being able to communicate a
hundred trillion numbers we can only
communicate what you could say in a
sentence which is not that many bits per
second yeah and so we're really bad at
communicating compared with these
current computer models that run on
digital computers it's almost infinite
they're able to that's a communication
band with this huge yeah because they're
exactly the same model they're clones of
the same model running on different
computers and because of that they can
see huge amounts of data because
different computers can see different
datas and then they can combine what
they learned more than any person could
ever comprehend far more than any person
could have become and yet somehow we're
smarter than them still okay so they're
like idiot savants right
chat GPT knows much more than any one
person if you had a competition about
you know how much you know it would just
wipe out any one person it was amazing
at bar trivia yes it would do amazing it
would do me and it can do all you can
write poems it can
you know
um they're not so good at reasoning
we're better at reasoning we have to
extract our knowledge from much less
data so we've got a hundred trillion
connections most of which we learn but
we only live for a billion seconds which
isn't very long
whereas things like chat GPT
have run for much more time than that to
absorb all this data but on many
different computers
1986 you publish a thing in nature that
is the idea we're going to have a
sentence of words and it'll predict the
last word yes that was the first
language model that's basically what
we're doing now yes and no 1986 was a
long time ago why still did people not
say oh okay I think he's on to something
oh because back then if you asked how
much data I trained that model on I had
a little
um simple world of just family
relationships there were 112 possible
sentences and I trained it on 104 of
them and checked out whether it got the
last eight right okay and how would it
do
it got most of the last eight right okay
it did better than symbolic AI so it's
just that the computers weren't powerful
enough at the time the computers we have
now are millions of times faster they're
parallel but they can do millions of
times more competition so I did a little
computation if I'd taken the
um
computer I had back in 1986
and I started learning something on it
it would still be running now and not
have got there huh
um and that's stuff that would now take
a few seconds to learn did you know
that's what was holding you back
I didn't know it I believe that might be
what was holding us back
but people sort of made fun of the idea
that
the claim that well you know if I just
had a much bigger computer and much more
data everything would work and the
reason it doesn't work now is because we
haven't got enough data on enough
compute that's seen as a sort of lame
excuse for the fact that your thing
doesn't work
was it hard in the 90s doing this work
in the 90s computers were improving but
um yes so there were other learning
techniques that are on small data sets
worked at least as well as neural
networks and were easier to explain and
had much fancier mathematical theory
behind them
and so people within computer science
lost interest in neural networks within
psychology they didn't because within
psychology they're interested in
how people might actually learn and
these other techniques looked even less
plausible than back propagation here
which is an interesting part of your
background you came to this not because
you were interested in computers
necessarily but because you were
interested in the brain yes I sort of
decided I was interested in Psychology
originally then I decided we were never
going to understand how people work
without understanding the brain the idea
that you could do it without worrying
about the brain that was a sort of
fashionable idea back in the 70s but
um I decided that wasn't on you had to
understand how the brain worked so we
fast forward now to the 2000s is there a
key moment you think back to is a
turning point when it's like okay
our side is going to Prevail in this
around 2006
we started doing what we call Deep
learning
um before then it had been hard to get
to neural Nets with many layers of
representation
to learn complicated things
and we find better ways of doing it
better ways of initializing the networks
called pre-training and the p in chat
gbt stands for pre-training okay
um and the t is Transformer and G is
generative and it was actually
generative models provided this better
way of pre-training neural ads so the
seeds of it were there in 2006 in by
2009 we'd already produced something
that
was better than the best speech
recognizers and recognizing which
phoneme you were saying using different
technology than all the other speech
recognizers were then then the standard
approach which you've been tuned for 20
for 30 years there were other people
using neural Nets but they weren't using
deep neural ads and then there's a big
thing happens in 2012. yes to actually
two big things okay one is that the
research we'd done in 2009 done by two
of my students over a summer that led to
better speech recognition
that got disseminated to all the big
speech recognition Labs that Microsoft
and IBM and Google
and in 2012 Google was the first to get
into a product and suddenly speech
recognition on the Android became as
good as Siri if not better
so that was a deployment of deep neural
Nets applied to speech recognition three
years earlier at the same time as that
happened within a few months of that
happening
two other students of mine
developed an object recognition system
that would look at images and tell you
what the object was and it worked much
better than previous systems how did
this system work okay there was someone
called Faith a Lee in her collaborators
that created a big database of images
like a million images of a thousand
different categories you'd have to look
at an image and give your best guess
about what the primary object was in the
image so the images would typically have
one object in the middle yeah and I
didn't have to say things like bullet
train or Husky or and
the other systems
were getting like 25 errors and we were
getting like 15 errors okay within a few
years that 15 went down to three percent
which was about human level and can you
explain in a way people would understand
the difference between the way they were
doing it and the way your team did it
I can try that's all we can hope for
okay
so suppose you wanted to recognize a
bird in an image okay the image itself
let's suppose it's a
200 by 200 image
that's got 200 times 200 pixels
and each pixel has three values for the
three colors RGB
and so you've got 200 by 200 by 3
numbers in the computer it's just
numbers in the computer right
and the job is
to take those numbers in the computer
and convert them to a string that says
bird
so how would you go about doing that and
for 50 years people in standard AI tried
to do that and couldn't
got a bunch of numbers into a label that
says bird
so here's a way you might go about it
at the first level of features you might
make feature detectors things that you
take little combinations of pixels okay
so you might make a feature detector
that said look if all these pixels are
dark and all these pixels are bright I'm
going to turn on okay and so that
feature detector would represent an edge
here okay a vertical Edge you might have
another one that said if all these
pixels are bright and all these picks as
a dark I'll turn on that would be if
each detector that represent in a
horizontal Edge okay and you can have
others for edges of different organs we
had a lot of work to do all we've done
is made a box right so we've got to have
a whole lot of feature settings like
that and that's what you actually have
in your brain okay so if you look in a
cattle monkey cortex it's got feature
detectors like that
um then at the next level
you might say if you were worried up by
hand you would create all these little
feature detectors at the next level you
would say
um okay suppose I have two two Edge
detectors that join at a fine angle
that could just be a beak so the next
level up will have a feature detector
that detects two of the lower level
detectors joining a fine angle okay
we might also
notice a bunch of edges that sort of
form a circle we might have a detector
for that okay then the next level up we
might have a detector that says hey I
found this beak like thing and I find a
circular thing in roughly the right
spatial relationship to make the eye and
the beak of a bird
and so at the next level up you'd have a
bird detector that says if I see those
two there I think it might be a bird
okay and you could imagine wiring all
that up by hand okay and so the idea of
back propagation is
just put in random weights to begin with
and now the featured textures would just
be rubbish whether it be garbage okay
okay but look to see what it predicts
and if it happened to predict bird it
wouldn't but if it happened to leave the
weights alone
um you got it right the connection
strings but if it predicts cat
then what you do is you go backwards
through the network and you ask the
following question
and you can ask this with a branch of
mathematics called calculus but you just
need to think about the question and the
question is how should I change this
connection strength so it's less likely
to say cat I'm more likely to say bird
that's called the ER the error the
discrepancy right okay and you figure
out for every connection strength how I
should change a little bit to make it
more likely to say bird and less likely
to say cat and a person's figuring that
out or the algorithm is set to work a
person has said this is a bird so a
person looked at the image and said it's
a bird it's not a cat it's a bird so
that's a label supplied by a person
but then the algorithm back propagation
is just a way of figuring out how to
change every connection strength to make
it more likely to say burden less likely
to say cat it just keeps trying keep
turning it just keeps doing that and now
if you showed enough birds and enough
cats when you showed a bird it'll say
burden when you showed a cat it'll say
cat and it turns out that works much
much better than trying to wire
everything by hand and that's what your
students did on this image database
that's why they did on the image check
device yes and they got it to work
really well now they were very clever
students in fact one of them Ilya
sutskova
is also one of the main people buying
chat gbt
so that was a huge moment in Ai and chat
gbt was another huge moment and he was
actually involved in both of them yeah
yeah
I don't know maybe it's cold in the room
you got to the end of the story I go
shivers
the idea that you do this little dial
thing and it says bird it feels like
just an amazing breakthrough yeah I it
was
um mainly because
the other people in computer vision
thought okay so these neural Nets they
work for simple things like recognizing
a handwritten digit but that's not a
real complicated image with sort of
natural background with stuff it's never
going to work for these big complicated
images and then suddenly it did
and to their credit the people who've
been really staunch critics of neural
Nets and said these things are never
going to work when they worked they did
something that scientists don't normally
do which she said oh it worked we'll do
that people see it as a huge shift yes
it was quite impressive that they
flipped very fast because they saw that
it worked better than what they were
doing yeah you make this point
that when people are thinking both about
their machines and about ourselves in
the way we think we think language in
language out must be language in the
middle yes and this is an important
misunderstanding yeah can you just
explain that I think that's complete
rubbish yeah
um so
if that were true
and it were just language in the middle
you'd have thought that approach which
is called symbolic AI yeah would have
been really good at doing things like
machine translation which is just taking
English in and producing French art or
something
your thought manipulating symbols was
the right approach for that but actually
neural networks work much better than
Google translate when they switched from
doing that kind of approach to using
your alerts really much better what I
think you've got in the middle is you've
got millions of neurons and some of them
are active and some of them aren't and
that's what's in there
the only place you'll find the symbols
are at the input and at the output
we're not exactly at the University of
Toronto we're close to University of
Toronto at universities here and around
the world we're teaching a lot of people
to code does this still make sense to be
teaching so many people to code
um I don't know the answer to that in
about 2015
I famously said it didn't make sense to
be teaching Radiologists to recognize
things in images
and because within the next five years
um computers will be better at it yeah
are we all about to be Radiologists
though well then Coopers are not better
I was wrong it's going to take 10 years
not five I wasn't wrong in spirit I just
got I factor of two computers are now
comparable with Radiologists at a lot of
medical images yeah they're not way
better at all of them yet but they will
get better yeah so I think there'll be a
while when it's still worth having
coders and I don't know how long that'll
be but we'll need less of them yeah
maybe or we'll need the same number and
they'll be able to achieve a whole lot
more
um was talking about cohere we went over
and visited them yesterday you're an
investor uh in them maybe maybe the
question is just like how they convince
you what was the pitch that convinced
you I want to invest in this so they're
good people
um and I've worked with several of them
yeah and they were one of the first
companies to realize that you need to
take these big language models being
developed to places like Google and
other places open Ai and
um make them available to companies
so there's going to be it's going to be
enormously valuable to companies to be
able to use these big language models
um
and so that's what they've been doing
and they've got a significant lead in
that
so
that's why I think they're going to be
successful another thing you've said
that I just find fascinating so I want
to get you to talk about it is
the idea that there'll be kind of a new
kind of computer that will be
sent to this problem what is that idea
so
there's the biological route to
intelligence where every brain is
different and we have to communicate
Knowledge from one to another by using
language
and there's the current AI version of
neural Nets where you have identical
models running on different computers
and they can actually share the
connection strength so they can share
billions of numbers this is how we make
a bird yeah so they can share all the
connection strengths for recognizing a
bird and one can learn to recognize cats
and the other can learn to recognize
birds and they can share their
connection strengths and now each of
them can do both things right and that's
what's happening in these big language
models they're sharing but that only
works in digital computers because they
have to be able to do identical things
and you can't make different biological
brains behave identically so you can't
share the connections yeah but why
wouldn't we stick with digital computers
because of the power consumption you
need a lot of power it's getting less as
chips get better but
um you need a lot of power to do this to
run a digital computer you have to run
it at such high power that it pays
exactly in the right way whereas if
you're willing to run at much lower
power like the brain is
then
you'll allow a bit of noise and so on
but that particular system will adapt to
the kind of noise in that particular
system and the whole thing will work
even though you're not running it at
such high power that it pays exactly as
you intended
and the difference is the brain runs on
30 Watts a big AI system needs like a
megawatt
so we're training on 30 watts and these
big a systems are using because they've
got lots of copies of the same thing
they're using like a megawatt so you
know you're talking factor of the order
of a thousand in the power requirements
and so I think there's going to be a
phase when we train on digital computers
but once something's trained
we run it on very low Power Systems
so if you want your toaster to be able
to have a conversation with you and you
want to chip in it that only costs a
couple of dollars
but can do chat gbt that'd better be a
low power animal chip what are kind of
like the next
things you think this technology will do
that will impact people's lives
it's hard to pick one thing I think this
it's going to be everywhere right it's
already sort of sort of getting to me
everywhere chat GPT is just made a lot
of people realize it it's going to be
everywhere but it's already you know
when Google does search it uses big
neural Nets to help decide what's the
best thing to show you we're at a
transition point now where
chat gbt is this kind of idiot savant
and it's also doesn't really understand
about truth
is being trained on
lots of inconsistent data it's trying to
predict what someone will say next on
the web yeah and people have different
opinions and it has to have a kind of
blend of all these opinions
so that it can model what anybody might
say
it's very different from a person who
tries to have a consistent world view
yeah particularly if you want to act in
the world
um it's good to have a consistent world
view and I think what's good one thing
that's going to happen is we're going to
move towards systems that
um can understand Different World Views
and can understand that okay if you have
this world view
then this is the answer and if you have
this other world view then that's the
answer we get our own truths well that's
the problem right because what you and I
probably believe unless you're an
extreme relativist is that actually is a
truth to the matter
certainly on many topics on many topics
or even most topics yeah like the Earth
is actually not flat it just looks flat
right
yeah so do we really want a model that
says well for some people like we don't
know that's going to be a big issue and
we don't know we don't know how to deal
with other present yeah and I don't
think Microsoft knows how to deal with
it either they don't and it seems to be
a huge governance challenge who makes
these decisions
it's very tricky things you don't want
some big for-profit company deciding
what's true but they're controlling how
we turn the neurons Google is very
careful not to do that at present
um
what Google will do is refer you to
relevant documents which will have all
sorts of opinions in them well they
haven't released their chat product at
least as we speak right um but we've
seen at least the people that have
released chat products feel like there
are certain things they don't want to be
said by their voice right so they go in
there and meddle with it so it won't say
offensive things yeah but there's a
limit to what you can do that way
there's always going to be things you
didn't think of right yeah so I think
Google is going to be far more careful
than Microsoft when it does release the
chatbot yeah and it'll probably
um come with lots of warnings this is
just a chatbot and and don't necessarily
believe what it says careful in the
labeling or carefullying in the way they
meddle with it so it doesn't do lousy
things all of those things careful in
how they present it as a product and
careful in how they train it yeah um
and do a lot of work to prevent it from
saying bad things and well who gets to
decide what a bad thing is
some bad things are fairly obvious but
many of the most important ones are not
yes so that is a big open issue at
present I think Microsoft was extremely
Brave to release chat GPT yeah do you
see this as like a larger some people
see this as a larger societal thing we
need either regulation or big public
debates about how we handle these issues
well when it comes to the issue of
what's true
I mean do you want the government to
decide what's true
speak problem right yeah you don't want
the government doing it either I'm sure
you've thought deeply on this question
for a long time how do we navigate the
line between you just send it out into
the world and we find ways to curate it
like I say I don't know the answer and I
don't believe anybody really knows how
to handle these issues we're going to
have to learn quite fast how to handle
these issues because
it's a big problem with president but
yeah how how it's going to be done I
don't know but I suspect as a first step
at least these big language models are
going to have to understand that there
are different points of view and that
completions it makes a relative to a
point of view some people are worried
that this could take off very quickly
and we just might not be ready for that
does that concern you
it does a bit until quite recently I
thought it was going to be like 20 to 50
years probably have general purpose AI
yeah and now I think it may be 20 years
or less so okay some people think it
could be like five
is that silly I wouldn't completely rule
that possibility out now and where's pre
a few years ago I would have said no way
okay and then some people say AGI
could be massively dangerous to humanity
because we just don't know what a system
that's so much smarter than us will do
do you share that concern
I do a bit
um
I mean obviously what we need to do
is make this synergistic
have it so it helps people and I think
the main issue here well one of the main
issues is the political systems we have
so I'm not confident that President
Putin is going to use AI in ways to help
people
like even if say the US and Canada and a
bunch of countries say okay we're going
to put these guard rails up then how do
you yeah it's it's
pretty for things like autonomous lethal
weapons
okay we'd like to have something like
Geneva conventions like chemical weapons
people decided they were so nasty they
weren't going to use them except just
occasionally but I mean basically they
don't use them people would love to get
a similar treaty for autonomous lethal
weapons but I don't think there's any
way they're going to get that I think if
Putin had an autonomous lethal weapons
he would use them right away this is
like the most pointed version of the
question and you can just laugh it off
or not answer it if you want but what do
you think the chances are of AI just
wiping out Humanity can we put a number
on that
it's somewhere between
100 percent
okay I think I think it's not
inconceivable
okay
that's all I'll say I think if we're
sensible
we'll try and develop it so that it
doesn't but what worries me is the
political Citizens We're in yeah where
it needs everybody to be sensible
there's a massive political challenge it
seems to me and there's a massive
economic challenge in that you can have
a whole lot of individuals who pursue
the right course and yet the profit
motive of Corporations may not be as
cautious as the individuals who work for
them
Maybe
I mean I only really know about Google
that's the only Corporation I've worked
in and they've been among the most
cautious they're extremely cautious
about AI because they've got this
wonderful search engine that gives you
the answers you want to see and
they can't afford to
risk that yeah whereas Microsoft has
Bingham well if being if being
disappeared in Microsoft would hardly
notice yeah
but it was easy for Google to take it
slow when there wasn't someone nipping
at their heels and this seems to be
exactly yeah so Google has actually been
in the lead I mean Transformers were
invented at Google right the big
language models early ones were at
Google but and they kind of kept it in
your lab they're being much more
conservative and I think it might be so
yes but now they feel this pressure yeah
and so they're trying to they're
developing a system called bad that
they're going to put out there and
they're doing lots and lots of testing
of it
um
but they're going to be I think a lot
more cautious than Microsoft
you mentioned autonomous weapons let me
give you a chance just tell the story
what's the connection between that and
how you ended up in Canada okay there
were several reasons I came to Canada
but one of them was certainly not
wanting to take money from the U.S
defense department this was at the time
of Reagan when they were mining the
harbors in Nicaragua
and it was interesting I was at a big
university in Pittsburgh
and I was one of the few people there
who thought that mining the harbors in
Nicaragua was really wrong
[Music]
um
so I felt like a fish out of water and
you saw that this was where the money
was coming from for this kind of work so
that department almost all lemon came
from the Transformer you started to talk
about the concerns that bringing this
technology to Warfare could present what
what are your concerns
oh that
um the Americans would like to replace
their soldiers by autonomous by AI
soldiers
and they're trying to work towards that
and what evidence do you see of them
I'm on a mailing list
from the U.S defense department I'm not
sure they know I'm on the meeting list
it's a big list they didn't notice
you're there you might be off tomorrow I
might be off tomorrow what's on the list
oh they just describe various things
they're going to do there's some
disgusting things on there okay we'll
discussed you the thing that disgusted
me most was a proposal for a
self-healing minefield
so the idea is look at it from the point
of view of the minefield
when some silly civilian trespasses into
the Minefield they get blown up and that
makes a hole in the poor my field so
it's got a gap in now so it's not fit
for purpose yeah so the ideas may be
nearby Minds could communicate or maybe
they could move over a bit
and they call that healing and it was
just the idea of
talking about healing for these things
that blow the legs off children I mean
and the healing being about the
Minefield healing yeah that disgusted me
there is this argument that though the
autonomous systems might play a role in
helping the Warfighter it's ultimately a
human making the decision here's what
worries me if you wanted to make an
effective autonomous Soldier
you'd need to give it you'd need to give
it the ability to create sub goals
in other words it has to realize things
like okay I want to kill that person
over there but to get over there how am
I going to get over there and then it
has to realize well if I could get to
that road I could get there more quickly
so it has a sub goal of getting to the
road
so as soon as you give it the ability to
create his own sub goals
it's going to become more effective
and so people like Putin are going to
want robots like that and but as soon as
it's got an ability to create sub goals
you have What's called the alignment
problem which is how do you how are you
sure it's not going to create sub goals
that are going to be
um not good for people not good for you
who knows who's on that road who knows
on that road and if these systems are
being developed by the military the idea
of wiring in some rule that says never
hurt a person
well that's they're being designed to
eat at people yeah
do you see any way out of this is it a
treaty is it what is it
I think the best batch is something like
a Geneva Convention but it's going to be
very difficult I think if there was a
lot of public outcry that might persuade
I can imagine the Biden Administration
going for something like that with
enough public outcry
but then you have to deal with Putin
yeah
um okay we've covered so much I think I
have like two more things there's one
more thing I want to say yeah yeah go
for it you can ask me the question some
people say that these big models are
just autocomplete well on some level the
models are autocomplete we're told that
the large language models they're just
predicting the next word is that not so
simple no that's true they are just
predicting the next word and so they're
just auto-complete but
ask yourself the question of what do you
need to understand about what's being
said so far in order to predict the next
word accurately and basically you have
to understand what's being said to bring
language so you're just already complete
too
um in the sentences they are you can
predict the next word maybe not as well
as chat gbt yeah but to do that you have
to understand the sentence so let me
give you a little example from
translation
it's a very Canadian example okay
suppose I take the sentence the trophy
would not fit in the suitcase because it
was too big
and I want to translate that into French
well when I say the trophy would not fit
in the suitcase because it was too big
you assume the it refers to Trophy I do
and in French
trophy has a particular gender so you
know what pronoun to use yeah but
suppose I say the trophy would not fit
in the suitcase because it was too small
now you think that it refers to suitcase
right and that has a different gender in
French
so in order to translate that sentence
to French you have to know when it
wouldn't fit in because it was too big
it's the trophy that's too big and when
it wouldn't fit in because it was too
small it's a suitcase that's too small
and that means you have to understand
about spatial relations and containment
and so on yeah so you have to understand
just to do machine translation or to
predict that pronoun if you want to
predict that pronoun you've got to
understand what's being said it's not
enough just to treat it as a string of
words yeah yeah
I mean this gets me to another thing
you've pointed out which is kind of a
either exciting or troubling idea that
you working intimately in this field for
as long as anyone describe the progress
as well we had this idea and we tried it
and it worked and so we get a couple
decades of back propagation we have this
idea for a Transformer now we'll do some
trick but it could there's hundreds of
other ideas that haven't been tried out
yes so I think even if we didn't have
any new ideas just making computers go
faster and getting more data will make
all this stuff work better we've seen
that as they scale up chat gbt it's not
radically new ideas there I think it's
just more connections and more data to
train it with yeah but in addition to
that there's going to be new ideas like
Transformers and they're going to make
it work much better are we close to the
computers coming up with their own ideas
for improving themselves
um yes we might be and then it could
just go fast that's an issue right we
have to
think hard about how to control that
yeah can we
we don't know we haven't been there yet
but we can try okay that seems kind of
concerning
um yes
do you have any you're seen as like a
Godfather of this industry do you have
any concern about what you've wrought
I do a bit on the other hand
I think
whatever's going to happen is pretty
much inevitable that is one person
stopping doing research wouldn't stop
this happening if my impact is to make
it happen a month earlier
that's about the limit of what one
person can do there's this idea of the
and I'm going to get it wrong the short
Runway and the long takeoff maybe we
need time to prepare or maybe it's
better if it happens quickly because
then people will have urgency around the
issue rather than like creep creep creep
do you have any like thoughts on this I
think time for repair would be good and
so I think it's very reasonable for
people to be worrying about those issues
now even though it's not going to happen
in the next year or two yeah people
should be thinking about those issues we
haven't even touched on job displacement
um which is just my mistake for not
bringing it up
is this just going to eat up just job
after job after job after job
I think it's going to make jobs
different people are going to be doing
the more creative end and less of the
routine end but what's the creative if
it can write the poem and make the movie
and all of that
well if you go back in history and look
at ATMs these cash machines came along
and people said that's the end of bank
tellers it wasn't actually the end of
Bank tell us
um the bank tellers now deal with more
complicated things
and take coders so people say you know
these things can do simple coding and
usually get it right you just need to
get it to write the program and then
just check it so you'll be able to work
10 times as fast
well either you could have
10 of the programmers well you could
have the same number the program as
producing 10 times as much stuff yeah
and I think there's going to be a lot of
trade-offs like that you'll the once
these things start being creative
they'll be hugely more stuff created
this is the biggest technological
advancement sense
is this another Industrial Revolution
what is this how should people think of
it
I think it's comparable in scale with
the Industrial Revolution or electricity
electricity maybe the wheel or maybe the
wheel
yeah
that was earlier yeah okay so buckle up
one of the reasons I got a Toronto got a
big lead in AI
is because of the
policies of the granting agencies in
Canada which don't have much money but
they use some of that money to support
curiosity-driven basic research okay and
so in the states
the funding comes you have to say what
what products you're going to produce
with it and so on yeah yeah some of the
government money quite a lot of it is
given to
professors to employ graduate students
and other researchers to explore things
they're curious about and if they seem
to be good at that then they get more
money three years later
and that's what supported both Joshua
Benja and me it was money for curing
curiosity driven basic research and
we've seen that before even through
Decades of not being able to show much
yes even through decades not being able
too much so that's one thing that
happened in Canada another thing that
happened was there's a Canadian
organization called the Canadian
Institute for advanced research
that provides extra money to professors
in areas where Canada is good and
provides money for professors to
interact with each other when they're
far apart like in Vancouver and Toronto
but also to interact with researchers in
other parts of the world
um like America and Britain and Israel
and so on and
see far setup of programming AI is set
at one originally in the 1980s which is
the one that brought me to Canada which
was in symbolic AI
yet you came I was an oddball okay I was
kind of weird because I did this stuff
everybody else thought was nonsense they
recognized that I was good at this kind
of nonsense and so if anyone's going to
do the nonsense it might as well be him
one of my letters of recommendation said
that it said you know I don't believe in
this stuff but if you want somebody to
do it Jeff engines to go okay
um and
then after that program finished I went
back to Britain for a few years and then
when I came back to Canada they decided
to fund a program in deep learning
essentially sentience I think you have
complaints with the even just how you
define that right yeah I
when it comes to sentience I'm amazed
that
um people can confidently pronounce
these things are not sentient and when
you ask them what they mean by sentient
they say well they don't really know
so how can you be confident they're not
sentient if you don't know what sentient
means so maybe they are already
who knows I think whether they're
sentient or not depends on what you mean
by sentient so you better Define what
you mean by sentient before you try and
answer the question are they sentient
does it matter what we think or does it
only matter whether it effectively acts
as if it is sentient
it's a very good question Matt
and what's your answer I don't have one
sure okay because if it's not sentient
but it decides for whatever reason that
it believes it is and it needs to
achieve some goal that is contrary to
our interests but it believes in its
interests does it really matter if in
any human I think a good a good context
to think of this in is an autonomous
Lethal Weapon yeah okay so it's all very
well saying it's not sentient but when
it's hunting you down to shoot you
um
yeah you're going to start thinking it's
sentient
we're not really caring not an important
standard anymore the kind of
intelligence we're developing is very
different from our intelligence so it's
this idiot savant kind of intelligence
yes so it's quite possible as
if it is a tool center is essentially in
a somewhat different way from us but
your goal is to make it more like us and
you think we'll get there and my goal is
to understand us oh okay no but yeah and
I think I think the way you understand
us is by building things like us okay so
that's I mean the physics is called
Richard Feynman said you can't you don't
can't understand things unless you can
build them that's the real test of do
you understand it and so you've been
building so I've been building yeah